the latest data show a rapid rise in
cases just as the last of the lockdown
rules are about to be rolled back
the r number a measure of how fast the
virus is spreading
is now between 1.2 and 1.4 roughly the
same as last week but new figures from
the office for national statistics show
more than 652 000 people in the uk
are estimated to have been infected in
the week up to july the 10th
that's a rise of almost 63 percent on
the previous week
and just look at how the third wave has
picked up speed
at the start of june the weekly rising
cases
was just seven percent scotland still
has the highest rate with one in 90
people infected
but england is catching up fast one in
95
had the virus rates were much less
common
in northern ireland where one person in
290 was infected
and in wales where it was just one in
360.
within england the prevalence was by far
the highest in the northeast with one in
30 people infected but there's big
regional variation
down in the southwest just one in 108
had the virus
and it's still far more common in young
people one in 35
compared to one in 500 of those over 70.
so what happens next well self-isolation
is a key part of the strategy to control
the virus
but separate data from the ons shows one
in ten people
aren't fully self-isolating after being
told to by test and trace
or the app a third of those isolating
develop symptoms themselves
underlining its importance anxiety
about the lifting of legal restrictions
next monday is high with 57 percent of
people telling the ons that they're
worried
64 intend to keep wearing face masks in
shops
and a similar proportion on public
transport
sixty percent say they'll keep avoiding
crowded places and almost a half will
stick to social distancing
on every measure the young are more
likely to return to normal behavior than
older adults monday is a critical moment
in this third wave
how bad it gets is partly down to
vaccine uptake but
also our appetite to stay cautious even
when the rules
are lifted